all right 20s now was reacted to our
breaking news in our monologue the
columnist from the hill that actually
brought to this story is John Solomon
Florida congressman Matt Gaetz is with
us in studio John I got to begin with
you mother may have a conflict that
leads directly to Russia I might
surprise some of my audience here as FBI
director the efforts that they were
using to actually help save a former FBI
and a CIA guy and we haven't seen this
guy in 11 years I am NOT concerned about
that one bit I don't care I think any
effort to save an American and robert
muller and the FBI I'm all for it I want
to be very clear the issue becomes the
hypocrisy of this because this is the
same Russian oligarch that they use it
in the manna for case and they never
pointed it out so that's a problem for
me not the little laws that are that
that were cited there might be a
violation of law but I'm kind of glad
they tried hard to save this guy that's
my natural gut yeah sure I mean I think
the real question is the whole rush of
collusion cases did someone ask a favor
in Russia right did Donald Trump collude
and try to get a favor well six or seven
years before that collusion was a
twinkle in the public's imagination the
FBI asked a favor of this same Oleg
Arcola gark that's now a client and a
witness against potentially Paul Amana
Ford and there's no disclosure we in the
public don't know it doesn't appear that
the courts know let me I and Muller ever
told Congress that they had asked this
oligarch great question I talked to the
Senate and House Intelligence by the way
they they they got the Russian oligarch
to pay 25 million actually a part of me
thinks it's genius but then don't use
the same guy against metaphor and don't
mention that you know the guy yeah I
think that's right I talked to the
Senate Intelligence House Intelligence
Committee Chairman from that time bill
Nelson of Florida Mike Rogers of
Michigan's they both said that we were
never briefed and they were surprised to
learn that such an operation occurred
without Congress being informed all
right I know people are talking about
the legality of this and there's a
specific law the anti-deficiency Act
which prohibits the government from
accepting voluntary services you know
what that to me is total BS this is like
the superfluous idiotic bureaucracy
I want that Americans say
I want us fighting to save that American
so I'm not faulting Muller for that I'm
applauding him actually which surprises
some people it's the hypocrisy and they
didn't mention that this is the same
oligarch in the metaphor case they
purposely kept his name out well and
Shawn your show and the great reporting
John has done has demonstrated that this
is but one conflict of interest
the Muller probe is an orgy of conflicts
of interest and any one of them taken
independently could potentially be
brushed aside but viewed in their
totality it shows how corrupt and biased
this investigation is also an important
point on this oleg arc Deripaska Senator
Tom cotton asked a question in February
as to whether or not Deripaska was
involved in the drafting of the dossier
with Christopher Steele is he and
Christopher Rea would not answer that
question in open santa pola tapes but
very very important that this very
oligarch could have had a role in
telling lies about Donald Trump and that
we still don't know that as the American
people right you do point out not only
the hypocrisy the double standard what
clearly seems to be John something
they're trying to hide in in this case
what what other issues surround us that
you you discovered because you cite
dozens of people here or at least a
dozen or fourteen people in your article
sources that we've never known this
before yeah
listen the people that first approached
me Robert Mother's old comrades of the
FBI who thought it was odd that they had
asked his favor of Deripaska and then
he's missing from this case even though
there's a lot of evidence connecting it
to him I want to go back to something
the congressman said when you wake up
tomorrow morning well I think you're
gonna know the answer to what Deripaska
did with the FBI in relationship to the
dossier stay tuned tomorrow morning
you're gonna learn something very
important about Deripaska and that's
something to do with the dossier mr.
Soloman give us a preview sir come to
the teasing that's my job same thing to
do with the DA say it maybe what he said
about its allegations that'll be the
news you know anything about this only
that Senator cotton seems to be on the
trail and that we didn't get answers in
open hearings that certainly raises a
lot of questions all the way people John
have been asking where you've been on
the show you've had a lot going on you
weren't feeling well welcome back we're
glad to have you back thanks congressman
good to see you yes and I know we're all
praying for a speedy recovery of our
fantastic first lady as well so many
millions of Americans joining us
absolutely she's been amazing and the
media's been so vicious to her I'm sick
of it
good to see in studio